the thing that's always been fun about
the evil dead franchise is its mixture
of gory horror and over-the-top ass
kicking
the demonic deadites that protagonist
ash faces can be terrifying fully
capable of taking over characters bodies
and ripping people apart but ash is a
guy who has a boomstick in one hand and
a prosthetic chainsaw in the place of
the other the fact that both the
monsters and the humans who fight them
are capable killers creates an
interesting challenge for turning the
franchise into an asymmetrical
multiplayer horror game in evil dead the
game in a lot of similar games a group
of players faces off against a single
human opponent who plays a frightfully
powerful killer the survivor team is
mostly trying to flee and stay alive
while the killer player is hunting them
down most of the time in evil dead
though the humans don't just run away
from the supernatural candarian demon
and its undead army they fight slicing
off dead heads and spraying monster guts
all over the place that fact led evil
dead the game developer saber
interactive to find a different way to
balance its game it still sees a group
of four players facing off against a
horror controlled by a fifth player but
both sides are active in different ways
and putting up a serious fight we played
about an hour of evil dead the game with
the developers recently and got a
first-hand sense of how the game is
balanced to capture the same feel of the
movie's mtv show that the humans will
kick dead-eyed ass and that the
candarian demon is an ancient force of
frightening power
for the humans the goal of every battle
in evil dead the game is to complete a
series of objectives while the player
controlling the invisible formless
candarian demon flies around the level
and tries to stop them or kill them
along the way it gives the game a sort
of player vs environment vs player feel
there are various ai-controlled enemies
scattered around evil dead's huge map
that the human team has to deal with
while they also have to resist direct
and indirect attacks from the demon
player a typical match goes like this
the human players start by quickly
searching nearby buildings for loot in a
way that's similar to battle royale and
other multiplayer only games your goal
is to gather melee and ranged weapons as
well as healing items and the gear you
find also has rarity levels that dictate
how good it is which makes it a good
idea to keep looking around for upgrades
to keep yourself alive once you're
looted up you have to start hunting
objectives first tracking down pieces of
a map then using that map to locate an
item called the candarian dagger with
the dagger in hand you can use its power
against boss enemies called the dark
ones located somewhere on the map
defeating them gets you the iconic
necronomicon which you then have to
defend for a set period of time in order
to win the match while deadites swarm in
and attempt to destroy it and claim
victory for the demon for the human team
there's a lot to accomplish meanwhile
the demon player's job is to kill slow
and distract however while the demon has
access to an army of deadites both the
random ones that appear on the map and
others they can summon on demand the
demon is at something of a power
disadvantage even the toughest deadites
can be pretty easily beaten by the
humans particularly if they work
together so rather than just trying to
overwhelm the human players the better
strategy is to harass them at key
moments set traps that can relay them
and possess them directly to turn them
against one another at the start of the
match the demon player doesn't know
where the humans are and has to track
them down following indicators when they
make noise by firing weapons or using
vehicles but the demon player does know
the locations the humans will eventually
reach in order to complete their
objectives so you fly around gathering
up infernal power from the environment
that you can spend on summoning more
deadites or leaving traps that you hope
the humans will stumble into those traps
create jump scares that don't directly
hurt the other team but increase each
player's fear meter when that meter is
high enough the humans become
susceptible to being possessed and
that's when the demon player can really
wreak havoc so in a lot of ways evil
dead feels like two games rolled
together
for the humans it's a third person
action game that's all about
coordination planning and ripping apart
enemies you'll want to dodge enemy
attacks while tearing into deadites with
things like pickaxes and chainsaws then
using finishing moves to take them out
with style
staying together helps keep your fear
down as does stopping and lighting
campfires or gathering by light sources
but time is of the essence so there's
always the enticing possibility of
splitting up to deal with different
objectives more efficiently
even if it's dangerous meanwhile the
candarian demon player is almost more of
a dungeon master in many cases finding
good spots to drop tougher enemies and
traps to slow the other team down and
waiting for the perfect moment to strike
with a possession when you possess a
deadite or a human though you're
suddenly thrown right into that third
person action game doing your best to
use a variety of abilities to slow down
or kill the humans it's an interesting
balance where both sides can feel
extremely powerful under the right
circumstances four humans can chainsaw a
dead boss down to nothing without too
much difficulty but a single possessed
human at the right moment and with the
right weapons can best an entire team it
makes for a surprisingly fraught and
strategic game that feels very different
depending on what side you're playing
there's also a lot of subtle variations
spread throughout that affects how you
play and which strategies you employ the
human team's roster is populated by a
number of characters from throughout the
evil dead franchise divided by their
roles on the team leader characters buff
teammates who are around them hunters
are good at ranged combat support
characters help keep others alive and
warriors excel at melee combat all of
the characters also have a unique
special ability which do things like
boost your attack power or lower your
team's fear at key moments matching
various special abilities and character
roles to your playstyle and your group's
needs make team composition an important
consideration as you start a match the
demon also has similar strategic
decisions to make with the option of
three different deadeye teams to use in
a match each with its own play style and
boss character that can be occasionally
summoned the warlord team focuses on
buffing regular deadites in combat and
utilizing a big tough boss character
while the puppeteer team puts its focus
on possessions and the necromancer team
provides you with the weaker but more
plentiful skeleton army from army of
darkness and in addition to everything
else you have to keep track of there's
also a race to level up your
capabilities while the other team
increases theirs the humans can loot the
environment to find bottles of a drink
called pink f that allows them to level
up various stats like the strength of
their melee attacks or their overall
health while the demon player levels up
by attacking the humans to increase the
strength of their deadites boost their
possession capabilities and amp up their
boss characters all the strategy
involved really helps evil dead feel
like it gives you a lot of tools to win
with victory hinging on smart teamwork
by the humans and clever attacks and
distraction by the demon what's most
satisfying though is how evil dead it
all feels the human team is constantly
on edge at any time they might open a
booby trap loot chest full of tiny ashes
or stumble into a jump scare that blasts
their screen with a gross monster face
but they're also working together to
absolutely dismember any deadites they
come across the demon player can possess
a deadite or a player and turn them into
a deadly tool but it can also troll the
other team taking over a car to drive it
in the opposite direction from an
objective or possessing a player and
quickly wasting all their ammo the
different options match the feel of the
various evil dead franchise entries
combining horror and humor saber
captures that evil dead feel in a
variety of other ways as well not the
least of which is the extensive voice
cast bruce campbell reprises the role of
ash in not one but four iterations one
from each of the three core evil dead
movies plus the version of the
characters seen in the stars show ash vs
evil dead
groovy the game also brings in other
actors to revisit their roles from the
show and the movies including ellen
sandwich and betsy baker from the
original evil dead and dana de lorenzo
and ray santiago from ash vs evil dead
the game even adds a little more to the
evil dead cannon expanding on backstory
elements related to raymond nobi the
archaeologists who first came across the
necronomicon in the film stories there's
a story reason why all these ashes and
other characters from throughout time
are fighting deadites in the same place
and that story is delivered in
single-player missions that are similar
to the multiplayer matches you'll play
in the game but don't quite constitute a
full-on single player campaign it's all
in service of an evil dead experience
that feels pretty similar to what fans
might expect from watching the movies
and tv show while adding something new
to the asymmetrical multiplayer horror
genre our time with evil dead the game
was frantic and often pretty hilarious
especially as the demon player pulled
unexpected tricks like possessing a car
and careening into our human team's
delta 88 completely flipping us over as
we desperately tried to reach the final
objective of the match before time ran
out it seems like evil dead is capturing
what fans of the franchise like about it
while exploring new territory in
asymmetrical horror by making everyone a
bit more of a badass
it'll be interesting to see how the game
fares with fans of the genre when it
releases on may 13th on playstation 4
ps5 xbox one xbox series x and s
nintendo switch and pc
[Music]
you